what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to another top 10 list here
on Comics explain and we're doing the
top 10 best fight scenes in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and just to shatter
your expectations here the fight at the
end of Avengers end game is not number
one on this list
number one I think is going to be a
little controversial to be honest with
you guys and I'm curious to see how
people respond to it but coming in at
number 10 on our list is the fight
between Taskmaster and black widow now I
love this fight I think it's one of the
absolute best fights the mcu's ever had
because it showcased black Widow at her
best and it gave us the best opinion of
what Taskmaster is capable of when it
comes to Natasha Romanov and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe she doesn't have much
to offer when it comes to a battle that
involves Thanos or the invasion of New
York or Ultron or something along those
lines but you put her in a room with
somebody and say that person needs to
die she's great when it comes to that
kind of a thing when it comes to
hand-to-hand combat she's virtually
Untouchable and I'm kind of amazed that
we never got a fight between her and
Steve Rogers in the MCU but what is cool
about this is that despite all of her
capabilities and everything we'd seen
her pull off over the course of her time
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe between
this movie and what would basically be a
time skip to what was effectively her
first appearance in the MCU when it came
to like Avengers and all that kind of
cool stuff and so on and so forth that
her skills hadn't changed all that much
now I don't say that to drag her down I
simply say that because how she fights
is basically the same so she is
essentially the same fighter in the
Black Widow film as she would be calm
and as she would be in the future of the
MCU meaning we basically saw her at her
best and when you have her at her best
going against someone like Taskmaster
and being painfully outclassed it's
amazing because Taskmaster to face off
against them isn't to face off against
just one person it's fighting an army of
people and to watch Taskmaster face off
against black widow while simultaneously
jumping between people like Captain
America and like Black Panther and Bucky
Barnes and even Black Widow herself it
was amazing to see and it was so unique
just in terms of hand-to-hand combat so
that's why we have it here at number 10
but coming in at number nine is probably
just one of the most epic fights ever
even if it didn't offer anything huge
and meaningful to the greater MCU the
fight between the Incredible Hulk and
the military and Edward Norton's
Incredible Hulk film I specify Edward
Norton because as most of you guys know
he played the Incredible Hulk in the MCU
before Mark Ruffalo which really kind of
begs the question which one of these
guys was a better Bruce Banner Mark
Ruffalo or Edward Norton Post your
answers down in the comments because I
want to know your opinions on this but
in this fight between the Incredible
Hulk and the military this was one of
those really really cool moments and
it's really more awesome because of the
context of the situation as opposed to
the re-watch ability of it in the sense
that when you go back and you look at
that whole conflict you wanted the
Incredible Hulk to win you wanted him to
overpower the military because you saw
the military as just this kind of
oppressive force that kept being used by
Thunderbolt Ross to try to capture the
Hulk and wouldn't just leave him alone
and so to watch that whole fight unfold
to see him turn into the Incredible Hulk
and to see him just lay waste to the
military which never had a chance in the
first place it was almost kind of like
sitting there and watching the man being
taken down right like bring Thunderball
Ross down a few pegs it was cool to see
and to see the look on Thunderbolt
Ross's face like oh [ __ ] okay uh so
we've been off more than we can chew
with this whole battle it was great it
was just this phenomenal moment but more
so than that and I think this is
something that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe just hasn't readily captured
outside of that moment and the events of
the first Avengers when basically the
Incredible Hulk was smashing things they
haven't captured that well right the
ability to just show The Incredible Hulk
tearing things up smashing stuff just
doing what he does best it's only been
shown a couple times outside of that
it's largely character development but
showing the Incredible Hulk just
smashing and destroying and so on I feel
like that moment in that film captured
it perfectly everything that you want
from The Incredible Hulk was right there
for you to see in that fight and it was
the first time we really got it but
coming in at number eight on our list I
think is just one of the most unique
moments in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in terms of fight scenes the fight
between doctor strange and Doctor
Strange not in Marvel's what if but in
the Multiverse of Madness and I don't
think this fight would have been
anything like what it was had it not
been then Sam Raimi who was behind the
creation of this film but what got this
fight scene on our list in the first
place was the unique nature of the fight
scene right the instance where like
Doctor Strange hits his fingers on the
piano and strums those musical notes and
then starts using music as a weapon
against himself it established a few
different things in the MCU the first is
that when you're using magic anything
and everything can be used as a weapon
but the second thing that it did is it
started laying down the rules and the
groundwork for how magic gets used in
the MCU because for the most part there
aren't really any rules at all it's just
what a person can do and what a person
can't do and that's basically it there's
really nothing else besides that being
able to alter reality being able to
transmogrify things and so on and so
forth but having this fight unfold in
such a unique way shooting musical notes
at each other guarding using musical
notes so on and so forth it made the
fight so unique and so spectacular and
so fun that I can go back and watch it
time and time again which really leads
me into the idea of a video that we need
to make here on comments explain which
is the top 10 most re-watchable moments
in the history of the MCU but coming in
at number 7 on our list is the first
fight between Black Panther and Eric
killmonger now I loved this fight if I'm
being honest there's a couple things I
would have changed for example what made
this fight so significant in the comics
is that it was Eric hillmonger with no
powers fighting black panther when he
had his powers but more so than that I
think this is one of those fights that
is so rewatchable and so amazing because
of the context of the fight itself that
up until that point when it came to
t'challa he was the rightful heir of the
Throne of wakanda right to Rule the
Kingdom as its new king when Eric
killmonger showed up he was like no I
challenge for that rule and he had a
legitimate claim to it not only that
what you knew was going to happen is
that these two guys would basically face
off one of them would rule but in
reality they both had legitimate
arguments they both had legitimate cases
for why they should do things Eric
hillmonger believed that wakanda staying
too hands off where's the problem right
that there were so many individuals out
there black Americans who were
struggling and that the power of wakanda
could be used to make the world a better
place more for the black community than
anything else at least that seemed to be
the message that was being sent across
there but beyond that it was one of
those things where sure like Eric
killemonger was willing to do some shady
things but it was all for the greater
good right sometimes you can't make an
armor without breaking a few eggs but
you looked at the path of of Chadwick
boseman's t'challa and you're like but
he's also got a point too and so you
didn't quite know which side to choose
you didn't quite know which one was
going to come out on top here but the
other thing that made it so awesome was
the context of the fight that the fight
was rooted in the culture of wakanda so
it was an extension of how wakanda
functions on a cultural level the kind
of history and things that they bring to
the table that whole thing was just
phenomenal but the other thing that made
this so awesome this is one of the
things I loved most about it the hero
lost the hero didn't win in that fight
and that's something that we were so
used to when it comes to superheroes in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is by and
large they usually always win and even
if they don't necessarily win they don't
lose like that by all standards and
measurements when that happened because
the movie came out after the events of
Civil War by all standard of measurement
it was like damn like is he gonna stop
being black panther like is this is this
it for t'challa he gets thrown off of a
cliff he doesn't have his powers there's
no real way for him to recover here
under any conceivable memes how in the
hell does a person survive that and it
was those kinds of questions that sort
of gave us this feeling even if it was
only temporarily and then we reminded
ourselves oh that's right it's a Marvel
movie don't worry he's going to be back
in the day he's going to be safe but it
was in that moment with that fight it
was like damn this might be the end of
him right that fight right there that
moment the whole thing that definitely
deserves a spot on this list but coming
in at number six which I assume it's
still part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'm a little fuzzy on where
things stand in terms of the canonicity
of stuff the fight between Punisher and
dared devil on Netflix now that fight
was great and the reason why is because
it was a fight between two guys but also
two philosophies there was no better
depiction of the punisher's philosophy
and how it stood against Daredevil than
when they're on the rooftop and The
Punisher tells Daredevil when you knock
them down they get back up when I knock
them down they stay down right and he
tells Daredevil you're a half measure
it's because of you that people keep
dying that you beat the hell out of
criminals and then they get let back out
on the street again right and Daredevils
oh you know they have rights you know
and the responsive Punisher was no right
they don't get that right like they lost
that when they started taking lies they
lost that they lost that right to to
life they lost the right to equality and
all that when they started committing
those heinous crimes and killing people
right like I fixed the problem you put a
Band-Aid on it and I love that
philosophy right I absolutely I love the
philosophy of the Punisher and I mean
here's the thing those are guys who are
new to comments explain I'm 100 a
villain oh I'm absolutely a villain give
me superpowers I'm gonna do some bad
stuff it's gonna be in in service to the
greater good right but like I'm gonna
break some eggs to make some omelettes
have no Illusions about that right I'm
not Captain America man I'm not gonna
take the high road
some folks are gonna die and that's just
the way that it is but it's one of those
things that's really really cool and and
I love that because it was a fight
between a guy who does what it takes to
get things done and a guy who doesn't
and so it was just this phenomenal thing
because the fight between the two of
them was just bare knuckle right knock
just knock down drag out brutal Netflix
fighting and I really hope they keep
that in the MCU I don't know if they're
going to but it was more of what these
guys stood for in terms of the two of
them fighting than it was anything else
but coming in at number five on our list
here it's probably one of the coolest
moments in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in recent memory the fight between the
Scarlet Witch and the Illuminati and I
loved this right A lot of people give it
give it crap you know because they're
like how could Reed Richards possibly be
the smartest man alive if he tells Wanda
how to defeat black Blackboard let's be
honest with ourselves Reed was doing
everybody a favor read Richard is like
John Krasinski knew Black Bolt sucks
read new Black Bolt sucks he's like I
mean this look this guy sucks he drags
down the team hey Wanda here's how you
kill Black Bolt so we can get this guy
done and out of the picture because
Black Bolt sucks right I mean you know
let's be honest with ourselves right he
sucks he had to go right but having her
face off against the Illuminati was cool
because what he did is I think it showed
one how ruthless Wanda had become how
far she had fallen but it also showed
how much control she had over her powers
it's one thing in the Battle of camartas
where she's shooting Fireballs in a
force field and trying to find a way to
penetrate it that's not overly
interesting what's really cool and what
I always enjoyed when it came to reality
warping were the small subtleties right
just taking away black Bolt's mouth and
having that be a a kind of in movie
illustration of how useless he is but uh
but it was cool right to see her just
use reality warping on that level and to
just show how powerful she was that she
was just crying rushing and taking all
Commerce it was amazing right I loved
that where she just demolished them all
it was great but coming in at number
four and this is really going to be one
of nostalgia the fight scene between the
Trinity and Thanos right Thor Captain
America and Iron Man against Thanos now
this is one of those moments where I
think I just showed how capable Thanos
was but the fight was just cool man
there was no greater meaning here there
was no higher philosophy right it didn't
fill us with existential dread right you
know it wasn't as though we were
watching this and our minds went to a
higher state of entropy it was just an
amazing moment where these guys were
fighting and and Thanos was just
countering all their moves just a team
up between the Trinity it was great but
I mean they were fighting to save
everything and all that kind of stuff I
mean you knew they weren't gonna beat
Thanos you know the entirety of like the
last 10 years of the MCU is not going to
come down to like Thor and Iron Man and
Captain America defeating Thanos and
like that's it but to see these three
three guys team up right and to see them
face off against Thanos and to see
Thanos hold his own against all of them
just one of the most beautifully shot
fight scenes there was so much emotion
and we as the fans it was just one of
those we just got caught up in the
moment and it was like oh my God this is
gonna be so great let's be honest with
ourselves though as soon as those guys
lined up to fight Thanos the first
question we had in our mind is this the
moment when Captain America picks up
Thor's hammer because we knew it was
gonna happen
we knew what was gonna happen but it was
really exciting and I absolutely loved
it but coming in at number three right
as you guys know when it comes to our
list the top three are when we really
start breaking out the big guns and when
we really start getting into the cool
stuff coming in at number three on our
list is Captain America and Bucky Barnes
versus Iron Man now this was just epic
and honestly I think one of the things
that led to this scene being so epic was
the trailer right the trailer for the
fight between these guys that's what was
so cool but in reality Man scene Captain
America and and Bucky Barnes fight Iron
Man again this wasn't one one of those
higher moment type things it was just
cool to see the things they were doing
in this fight right like to literally
see like Bucky Barnes smash Iron Man
with a shield and throw it to Captain
America and Captain America just started
hammering away on Iron Man's suit it was
the fact that like Bucky and and Captain
America were just working in such Unison
together not only that man and let's be
honest with ourselves it was kind of
cool to see him bring Tony Stark down a
few pegs Lord knows he needed it
he absolutely needed it but it was just
one of those things where like Captain
America was was literally fighting on
behalf of his best friend and the whole
wide world but like the choreography the
music the whole nine yards just one of
the most epic moments ever one of the
most epic fight scenes ever in the
history of Marvel but that brings us
into number two now number one is not
avengers end game obviously it's number
two here this fight was epic it was
Grand in scale it was cool to see and
scale right to basically have everything
that happened over the last 10 years
lead up to this one a lot of you guys
are just like well then what's number
one what's number one it was really cool
to see like the last 10 years lead up
into this whole thing now it was the
setting that made this fight scene so
epic it was the setting that made this
battle so awesome because you literally
have what's left of the superhero
Community those individuals who gathered
together who faced off against Thanos
the ones who survived the snap right
they were getting absolutely crushed
Thor's down Captain America's down
Captain America only guy who gets back
up and then you get the the little radio
broadcast that comes in where like Sam
Wilson's like cap on your like are you
there he's like on your left and like
the portals start opening and all these
people start coming out and it's the
Guardians of the Galaxy it's Spider-Man
right it's it's just all these Heroes
who were dusted and it's just this
amazing huge epic Ash moment where all
these folks show up by the way I'm still
one of those guys who believed that
moment would have been all the more epic
if it had been like the X-Men who had
shown up and like the eternals if they
wanted to be useful for a change in
their existence like all those different
things it would have been so cool but
the fact remains all those portals
opening right and then it's just like
the music's building and it's like
you know and like it all just stops and
then Captain America is like Avengers a
symbol right and just like like I
remember sitting in the theater when
that happened and it was just it was it
was so great because it had all built up
to that point everything that had
happened over the last 10 years had
built off to that giant battle between
all the superheroes that we had met
going against the forces of Thanos and
that of that whole fight scene had just
so many beautiful and wonderful moments
and what was so cool about that they
never lost anybody's identity in that
fight and it's very easy to do it's very
easy to lose the identity of Peter
Parker where he's the one that's kind of
young and he's vibrant he's a little bit
lost but trying to be serious at the
same time trying to kind of figure out
what the superheroes are supposed to be
doing Captain America being Captain
America Sam Wilson being Sam Wilson but
he was just this beautifully shot moment
and there were a lot of people who had
vendettas Wanda taking out her Vengeance
on Thanos because Thanos had killed
Vision it was just so many emotions and
so much so much feeling that had been
brought into that fight that we were on
the edge of our seat the entire time and
honestly there's only been one moment
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe where
I think we were ever more just excited
than that hyped up than that and that of
course my friends and that of course my
friends is the team up between Tom
Holland Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield and Spider-Man no way home now
here's the thing we had been looking
forward to this for years ever since we
got Toby Maguire's Spider-Man and the
Multiverse came back in Loki the
question we had was are we going to see
a Spider-Man team up how cool would it
be to have Toby McGuire team up with Tom
Holland or to bring Andrew Garfield back
or to finally give Andrew Garfield the
third Spider-Man movie that we know he
deserves even though all of you guys
hated Spider-Man 2 and you hated Andrew
Garfield and you never wanted to see a
third one but you're only jumping on
board now because of Spider-Man no way
home yes I'm calling you out stop lying
you weren't there when he needed you in
Spider-Man 2 you don't get to be there
for him now but the the big thing and
what made this moment so cool what made
this fight so phenomenal is that your
talking about three generations of
Spider-Man teaming up and it was really
more than Nostalgia that made this fight
so awesome it was the Nostalgia of it
all because for a lot of people like me
we we were there during like blade which
is why a lot of us have really been
requesting the return of Wesley Snipes
in some capacity but the first real
great comic book movie that had come out
was Sam rainey's Spider-Man it's kind of
the thing that set it all off right the
current movies as they existed at that
point in time you had a yeah Spider-Man
by Sam Raimi then you had the X-Men then
you had the Fantastic Four again blade
is really the one that saved superhero
films we got to give that guy his do had
it not been for blade none of those
movies would have came after let's just
get that out of the way right now but
Sam Ray me Spider-Man it's Nostalgia for
us it's our childhood for a lot of us we
grew up on those movies and so to see
Toby Maguire return as Spider-Man team
up with Andrew Garfield who I still say
was a phenomenal Spider-Man and was
criminally underrated until no way home
when people who either weren't exposed
to him or people who just changed their
minds decided they wanted to be fans of
him that he teamed up with Tom Holland
we had all these versions these three
versions of Spider-Man from three
generations coming together and
operating as a team it was just one of
the greatest moments and then you had
like just the giant thing of them
leaping in right and it's that whole
segment it's not even just the fight
with these guys it's the whole segment
right Spider-Man one what is it like
Peter one Peter two Peter three you know
it was it was it was that whole thing
right we laughed we cried honestly I
still say this moment right the
Spider-Man no way home team up was a
better fight scene and I say it was more
epic than Avengers end game but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later